my name is Melbourne Knoll and I'm a
part-time truck driver and and I own
this miniature golf course and also the
go kart track out here that certain
morning I happen to look over into the
sky to the northeast and I seen a very
very bright light up there like a very
bright store and then I said well that's
moving and I just stood there and watch
it as what I was doing it never just
coming down out of the sky real slow and
no noise just quiet and I couldn't see
no wings or nothing just floating right
through the mid air up there and I
thought well if I don't tell nobody that
I've seen something go over town then I
know but I believe me tomorrow nul drove
his truck to the Highland Illinois
Police Department to report an
unidentified flying object heading
toward the neighboring town of Lebanon
mother just received a call from
Highland PD reference to a truck driver
just stopped in and said there was a
flying object in the area's webmin kill
right no this is not a joke that's what
up Eadie Barton was the first police
officer to respond to the call her
father's a very bright light light east
of town and agitation color heading west
on mount arab activists a philosophic of
a theater now
at 4:23 a.m. police officer David Martin
saw the UFO over a field on the
outskirts of Shiloh I happened to look
over and saw this large floating object
that was just moving very slowly it was
probably about a football field in
length they had three large bright
lights lighting up the sky underneath it
I honestly don't know what it was that I
saw other than I know it wasn't a plane
or a helicopter or a blimp police
reported the object over Lebanon over
Shiloh over Milstead overdue poe
detective mark Lupino says he saw it as
it approached a fallon illinois I was
driving eastbound on highway 50 when I
see the object the UFO if you will I
first thought it was probably a bunch of
helicopters flying in some type of
formation as I drew closer to it I saw
it start to cross over the roadway it
was unlike anything I have ever seen
before you could see the lights and you
could see something that they were
attached to and it was shaped like a
triangle
I'm freaking out I'm like what the heck
is this so I continued and it's going
over these trees by time I get here
toward the left turn lane I duck into
the last left turn lane here and I stop
right about here I wanted to listen this
if I get here any type of engine noise I
could not hear anything I tried to look
again at the UFO and it had already gone
behind these trees I put it in reverse
to back up a couple seconds to see if I
could rewrite to see it it had moved at
least a mile away if not further that
quick I was just astonished I didn't
know what to say I was speechless
six people including five police
officers saw an object over southern
Illinois that night they all described
what they saw as a massive triangular
object flying in total silence